En este video vamos a hablar del Conjunto potencia
y su cardinal. Si definimos el conjunto A como el
conjunto que tiene las letras a y b, podemos decir
que su cardinal es 2. Si la palabra "cardinal" o
"cardinalidad" no te suena familiar, te recomiendo
que revises nuestros videos de conjuntos;
pero esta vez hablaremos del conjunto potencia del
conjunto A. El Conjunto potencia es el conjunto
de todos los subconjuntos del conjunto A, y
denotamos el conjunto potencia de A como P(A),
así que veamos qué subconjuntos tiene el conjunto
A. Primero tenemos como subconjunto al conjunto
vacío, porque, recuerda, el conjunto vacío
está en todos los conjuntos si quitamos todos
sus elementos, no olvidemos entonces el conjunto
vacío. Después tenemos al conjunto que tiene la
letra a. Si observas el conjunto que contiene
la letra a está contenido en el conjunto A o,
dicho de otra manera, es un subconjunto ya que
todos sus elementos están en el conjunto A. Pasa
lo mismo con el conjunto que contiene a la letra
b: el conjunto que contiene la letra b es también
un subconjunto del conjunto A, y también debe de
estar en el conjunto potencia de A. ¿Nos faltará
alguno? ¡Claro!, nos falta el conjunto A mismo, es
decir, el conjunto que contiene a a y b, ya que el
conjunto A es un subconjunto del conjunto A. De
nuevo, puedes verlo de esta manera: todos sus
elementos están en el conjunto inicial A. Entonces
ya está, el conjunto potencia de este conjunto A
es el conjunto que contiene, primero, al conjunto
vacío, después el conjunto que contiene la letra
a, después el conjunto que contiene la letra
b y, por último, el conjunto que contiene las
letras a y b, es decir, el mismo conjunto A. Ahora
bien, podemos ver que el cardinal de este conjunto
potencia de A es 4, y ¿existirá una relación entre
el cardinal de A y el cardinal de la potencia de
A? Piénsalo un poco. Bien, veamos otro ejemplo.
Ahora tenemos el conjunto B. ¿Cuál es el conjunto
potencia del conjunto B y cuál será su cardinal?
Pausa el video e intenta encontrarlo. Muy bien,
vamos a trabajar juntos. El conjunto potencia que
denotaremos como P(B) es el conjunto que contiene
todos los posibles subconjuntos de B, ¿cierto?
Entonces, vamos a escribirlos con cuidado:
primero tenemos el conjunto vacío (recuerda que
el conjunto vacío siempre es un subconjunto de
cualquier conjunto), bien, después trabajaremos
con los subconjuntos de un solo elemento y después
con los subconjuntos de dos elementos, y así
seguiremos. Los subconjuntos unitarios son tres:
el conjunto que contiene sólo el uno, el conjunto
que contiene sólo el 2 y el conjunto que contiene
sólo el 3. Después vamos a trabajar con
los subconjuntos que tienen dos elementos,
para encontrarlos fijaremos un elemento e iremos
cambiando el otro. Hay que tener cuidado de no
repetir conjuntos, por ejemplo, si fijamos el
1 tenemos dos posibles subconjuntos el  y
el , es decir, fijamos el 1 y lo combinamos
con los otros dos elementos del conjunto B. Ahora,
hagamos lo mismo con el 2: fijamos el 2 y
tenemos dos posibles subconjuntos el
y el . Pero cuidado, el  y el  son
conjuntos iguales, entonces, para no repetirlos,
sólo escribiremos el . Si hacemos lo
mismo con el 3, es decir, si fijamos el 3,
tenemos dos posibles subconjuntos: el  y el
, pero ambos se repiten: el  y el
son conjuntos iguales, entonces no tenemos que
anotarlo, y el  es lo mismo que el ,
entonces tampoco habrá que anotarlo para
no repetir subconjuntos. Por último,
trabajemos con el subconjunto con tres elementos.
En este ejemplo sólo tenemos uno de ellos,
que es el conjunto B, es decir, el conjunto
. Recuerda: B siempre es un subconjunto
de él mismo. Y ya está, ya tenemos todos los
posibles subconjuntos del conjunto B: el vacío,
el conjunto que contiene el , el conjunto que
contiene el , el conjunto que contiene el ,
el conjunto que contiene el , el conjunto
que contiene el , el conjunto que contiene
el , y el conjunto que contiene el {1,
2, 3}, es decir, la potencia de B, y podemos
ver que la potencia de B tiene 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7, 8 elementos, entonces su cardinal es 8.
De nuevo, ¿habrá una forma de relacionar el
cardinal de un conjunto con el cardinal de su
conjunto potencia? Bueno, pues la respuesta es
sí, podemos encontrar el cardinal del conjunto
potencia con la siguiente fórmula: el cardinal del
conjunto potencia es igual a 2 elevado al cardinal
del conjunto original, y lo puedes ver aquí, en el
primer ejemplo tenemos que el cardinal de A es 2,
entonces, utilizando esta fórmula, el cardinal
del conjunto potencia del conjunto A debe de ser
2 elevado al cuadrado, que es igual a 4 elementos,
es decir, el cardinal del conjunto potencia de A
es 4, que fue justo lo que obtuvimos. En este
otro caso, el cardinal de B era 3, por lo tanto,
el cardinal del conjunto potencia de B es igual
a 2 elevado al cubo, que es igual a 8: tenemos
ocho elementos. Esto es bastante emocionante,
¿cierto? ¿Qué pasará con un conjunto D con
cuatro elementos m, n, o, p? Según la fórmula
que acabamos de ver, ¿cuántos elementos debe de
tener su conjunto potencia? Bueno, el cardinal del
conjunto potencia de este conjunto D es 2 elevado
al cardinal del conjunto D, es decir, a la cuarta
potencia, y 2 elevado a la cuarta potencia es 16,
así que esperamos un conjunto potencia con
dieciséis elementos. Te invito a que hagas
este ejercicio y nos escribas tu resultado. ¿Lo
lograste? No olvides agregar al conjunto potencia
el conjunto vacío y el conjunto D. Además,
ten mucho cuidado con los conjuntos repetidos:
primero ordena los conjuntos con un elemento,
después los conjuntos con dos elementos,
después los conjuntos con tres elementos y, por
último, el único conjunto con cuatro elementos
que estén. Espero que este video haya sido
de gran utilidad para ti. Hasta la próxima.